looks like I'm showing off all the time
here's what you don't know you don't see
all the hard work the years the years
don't quit okay if I had to quit I
wouldn't have the wife wouldn't have the
kids wouldn't have the bird wouldn't
have the cars wouldn't have the real
estate wouldn't have my physical and my
mental health I wouldn't have the
success nobody would know me nobody
would know me so you see where I'm at
today but you don't see all the days
that I got up when I didn't want to get
up all the days when I went to work and
made a call when I didn't want to make a
call all the days that I called somebody
back that had rejected me over and over
and over again all the book publishers
that wouldn't publish my books all the
TV people that said no man you're too
noisy all that all the things that are
happening to you right now the sick days
the illnesses the family that's pulling
against you the friends that counted you
out the problems you've had in your past
whatever it is look you can use it as an
excuse or you can use it as fuel hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
quit on my business partner I was making
300 bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from
some
Joy
hack number two is stop complaining with
Gary vaynerchuk my friends you want to
talk about something that is completely
something nobody talks about
nobody talks about saving money
like
it's just not a conversation
like there's a very easy way to do this
if you make forty nine thousand a year
live as if you're making 27.
everybody lives over what they make no
wonder you can't save money your
apartment's too nice
of course you can't save money your car
is too fancy
of course you can't save you're buying
clothes you can't afford they're that
complain to me
and this is where I'm listen if you're
dming me or emailing me know that I
don't fool around
when you DM me and say
[Laughter]
I can't I can't the first thing I do is
go to your account
don't let me hear that your broke is
and the first story I click on you're
drinking a seven dollar coffee
if you're broke you're not allowed to
take Uber
take the bus
[Applause]
we need to start saving money to get a
are you in a spot are you in debt you
don't like it there's gonna be no fast
track to a million dollars that's going
to fix that it's going to be taking a
step back and drinking a whole lot of
humility not a French latte
I don't get it people are always like
Gary your story about you building your
dad's business that's not true like you
like that can't be true you had money to
invest in Twitter and all that I know
your story I'm like okay right because
when I made 53 000 a year I had a two
thousand dollar a month apartment then I
moved down to a fourteen hundred dollar
one because I wanted to save more money
and I bought nothing for a decade I went
out zero times I bought no clothes I
wore liquor t-shirts to work hahaha
I spent no money
not super complicated I
will hear immigrants or the children of
immigrants raise your hands raise them
high
how many people are the children of Keep
Your Hands Up
and how many are the actual immigrants
awesome immigrants have this figured out
immigrants come here they work and they
save money
I went up one and a half vacations my
entire childhood
we want to actually we went to Orlando
the Holiday Inn
and my mom ate like one sandwich in the
week
immigrants
[Laughter]
immigrants everybody cries about
immigrants they don't spend money on
dumb [ __ ] try it
try it
save money and then do your thing hack
number three is model success with Ed
mylett think about this Steve Jobs was
in his 20s and teens when he started
Bill Gates Mark Cuban Kylie Jenner you
taught any entrepreneur that's out there
today that you know pretty well most of
them started young Jay-Z started young
LeBron James started young why is it
that you can't start young Steve Jobs
did I did Cuban did Bill Gates did all
there's thousands of entrepreneurs in
fact the the list of billionaires in the
country gets younger every single year
as do the millionaires you want to know
why because of these things right here
technology your phone your iPad social
media allows people at any age to win
including pre-teen and teenagers and so
please parents don't hold your kids back
if they want to grow now now that we can
get rid of that myth what should I be
working on well the first thing is this
I think you need to start to read books
on persuasion and influence and when
you're watching social media or YouTube
or listening to audio somebody like
myself study their style study How They
Roll their words out their vocabulary
begin to model them and then modify to
your style model and modify model people
and then modify it's going to be your
ability to persuade people to influence
people to cast a vision to transfer
energy at any age of your life that's
going to determine how far you go so
start to study the great communicators
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there hack number four is eliminate your
scarcity mindset with jaspreet Singh
when we talk about Building Wealth
whether in a recession not a recession
the majority of people I think assume
that it's a lack of tool set that's
stopping them from getting to where they
want to go when in reality for the
majority people it's a lack of mindset
most of us have access to the tool set
it's just our mindset that's lacking you
don't need a ton of money what's the
mindset problem the mindset is one
believing I don't have enough money I
don't have access enough tools I don't
have access to enough things to go into
it that if I want to go and build a
business I need this this and this I
need ten thousand dollars I need a
hundred thousand dollars to go out and
do that I need to have this type of
degree I need to have this type of
parent I need to have access to these
types of people in order to go out and
build a successful business if I want to
go and invest my money I need ten
thousand dollars before I can invest for
it to be worthwhile why would I want to
start investing with ten dollars what is
that going to do when in reality these
small Investments do build up if you are
21 years old today and you start by
investing just a hundred dollars a month
which is just over three dollars a day
and you do this consistently until you
retire until you're 65 years old 66
years old and you can get an average 10
return on your money that doesn't mean
it's a 10 return every single year it's
an average 10 return over the course of
investment which is the average stock
market return you will retire a
Millionaire on that 100 investment
assuming you never increase the amount
of money you're investing and we're
talking about less than four dollars a
day
that that's a hundred dollars a month
not a one-time hundred dollars hundred
dollars a month yeah yeah less than four
dollars a day you put a hundred dollars
a month for the rest really 40 years and
so even if you get a raise and you never
put another Penny into your Investments
you will be able to retire a Millionaire
on the four dollars a day that you're
putting aside hack number five is find
smart people with Glenn Stearns I
found that when I
would instead of focusing again on the
fact that maybe I'm not the best reader
maybe I don't retain a lot very you know
a lot of things well instead of that
the fact that if I find smart people and
it's very cliche but it's very true and
I surround myself with them that I end
up looking smarter
right because and and you watch some
people and I would it can give you so
many examples of people
but I won't okay that that are in fear
that if I surround myself with someone
smarter than me it'll make me look dumb
right and and so they surround
themselves with people inferior and then
your whole company or division or
whatever you're in
fails right versus people that have
enough confidence to say wow you can
fill in the you know the blind spot I
don't have or my weakness and you fill
it all in and your whole company Rises
or whatever you're doing your whole
project Rises because all of you combine
to make this Uber's you know quick fast
smart
um project go right and so that became
pretty evident to me because I didn't
have a lot of the skills that why don't
I let those people do it you know why
don't I bring in more people and the
more talent I brought in the quicker we
went you know and the less time we
wasted and I went all right I think I'm
onto some here you know and then to
admit it hey I'm not the smartest guy in
the room you know I'm the chairman of my
company I hate running the meetings I
don't I don't like being the one that
has to tell people what to do I'm not
good at that I have I like the the
vision right I like I got an idea I'll
let you march up this hill that's fun to
me but the details let's let people like
to do that better
than I do do it and act number six the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is ensure of future income with
Lewis house lesson number six ensure a
future income so we've already talked
about making passive income and the
importance of setting aside money for
long-term Investments to have recurring
revenue flowing in so I'll hold off on
repeating myself there but in addition
to that there are a couple other ways to
ensure a future income that I want to
talk about the first is investing in
yourself this is massive the best way to
ensure you have a future income is to
make yourself recession-proof by
continuing to learn new skills and
building a strong personal brand we talk
about this in greatest Academy which
I'll share with you more in just a
moment and there are a lot of ways to do
this and it doesn't mean you have to try
to get a million followers on our
Instagram or become famous on Tick Tock
it could be as simple as creating a
website to Showcase your designs if
you're a graphic designer and networking
with other designers in your local area
at meetups or conferences and events and
if you're a business coach it could mean
posting videos on YouTube showcasing
your expertise and I know a lot of you
will hear that and you'll think well
Louis I've done that but I haven't got a
lot of views or shares or comments and I
understand I won't lie to you and say
numbers don't matter at all but they're
not the most important parts even if you
don't get views or shares or likes
publishing content that's aligned with
your personal brand shows you're passion
about it and it can set you up for
future success it shows you care about
the work you do and it allows others to
be able to see that as well nobody paid
attention to the content I put out for a
long time but consistently showing up
for over a decade has led to me living
my dreams and being on the path to
accomplishing all my goals and really
setting me up for Financial Freedom the
days of old-fashioned resumes are over
nowadays everything we publish online is
a resume so that YouTube channel always
started as a part of your resume our
LinkedIn profiles our resume our website
our Instagram Tick Tock all these things
they're part of our resume so be
productive and proactive and start
building your personal brand based on it
don't Rob the world of your talents
that's what would be selfish be proud of
the work you do and showcase the gifts
you were given and it might seem like
doing that won't help you much in the
short term and maybe it won't but
believe me in the long run it's one of
the best things you can do for yourself
to really ensure your future income is
guaranteed and recession-proof yourself
by building your personal brand and
another way to ensure a future income is
launching a side hustle and as of right
now one in three people in the United
States have a signed business and
another 25 percent are planning to start
one in the next year so you'd be in good
company if you decided to launch one if
you haven't already using your nights
and weekends to build up another source
of revenue for you can help provide I
find Financial cushion if you lose your
job or if the economy goes through
another recession like the pandemic and
it can also provide you with more money
to put into your savings your stocks
your bonds real estate or wherever
you're investing right now
you have to learn to practice presence
practice presence being here fully in
the moment a live vibrant or at least
attentive right snapping your brain out
of that reactive like uh go with the
flow mode to no and being here
that oldest advice in all of personal
development about presence and awareness
about being with the flow about being in
the moment there's every spiritual
tradition has taught it as being Central
to human happiness and connection
this has been stolen from us because of
this I really believe I I I'm stunned
when I hang out with people that they
can't be present for three minutes
without wanting to scroll through
something I mean they can't be I mean
even four or five minutes they can't do
it anymore because they have trained
themselves with millions of swipes
to be not present
and I believe that meaning and
fulfillment
um they become too fleeting
when we haven't learned to be really
present
and I think that's important learning to
be really fully present
and pulling that from ourselves there's
plenty of times I mean if you saw my
schedule you're like how do you get
present I'm like I've trained myself
otherwise I can just be pulled in the
next thing there's always a million
things going on around me and I have to
learn to just zoom right in and be here
with you
you have to teach yourself to do that
too
because the more days that Blur by the
less sense of meaning or fulfillment you
have
you can be busy
but the days don't Blur by
right I'm incredibly busy I'm actually
this last two years I can't believe how
busy we got but during that time present
forcing myself each day to get present
so I can recognize and appreciate those
little moments so I can create the
connection with other people
so that I can sense that spiritual
aliveness of being here now versus
hoping one day to arrive to something
and that that practice of cultivating
presence of I would say and I know
people don't like when I use this phrase
but demanding presence I demand of
myself to be present I because I know
when I'm not I'm like Brendan get
present okay so I might bounce in place
take 10 deep breaths just to reset my
brain and my body
and that 10d maybe you do it right now
with me just stand up wherever you're at
bounce in place a little bit take 10
deep breaths
re-center yourself to the moment and
keep going
and that way you can observe life many
people they'll work their whole career
then they'll retire and they'll retire
and they'll finally be like oh wow look
at the color of the trees this is
amazing wow life looks pretty good and
they didn't even see it for five six
years they missed all of it even though
they were amidst all of it they just
missed it you have to teach yourself to
be with it to be here meaning and
fulfillment is so much as much as we can
Define it and have a destiny mindset we
can feel it
like I do it for like if I have a great
dinner with Denise like things go great
we just have a nice conversation I'll
walk away and I'll like be like putting
things away and just literally thinking
my mind
what a blessing
God I made it
thank you so much for this blessing to
be here with my wife what a great day
what an amazing moment we just had you
know what years later I'm going to
cherish that dinner
simple as that it's what we say to
ourselves
in the minute and after the minute that
really defines how we feel over the long
term isn't true
I mean the little moments if you can
celebrate them be there for them give
thanks for them I believe the more you
give thanks for the moments in your life
the more meaning you find
the more you give thanks for the moments
in your life the more you feel fulfilled
even if you feel years away even if the
next big thing is out there it's okay
right now you're feeling it that's what
presence is it's about feeling the day
more you hear me teach this now for what
20 years like you have to learn to feel
life
if we don't feel it then what's it about
and you're not just going to suddenly
one day feel it you know because you
drank a bunch of coffee maybe you are
but you're you're gonna you're gonna
imagine me on Kathy one day you're just
gonna you're gonna teach yourself to
feel the day and feel the moments more
you're going to observe more you're
going to breathe more
you'd have more intention and as you
learn to feel the day when someone says
hey you feel fulfilled about your life
you're like I do
because you are filling life
with presence when you fill life with
presence you feel full filled
it takes an active participation on your
point you're not just gonna show up one
day and feel fulfilled you have to fill
the day
with those senses of gratitude and
meaning and really
um I would say connection
if you don't do that I promise the days
just Blur by and the more they Blur by
the more you just stack on everybody
else's reactions needs desires drives
distractions their meaning and one day
you show up and you're just
you're really just a bag of everyone
else's intentions and needs and drives
and labels and meanings
and in that place
you're not autonomous
in that place
you don't get to experience that
individual sense of meaning and
fulfillment we've talked about from the
very beginning because you didn't take
the time to Define it consistently
enough you must visualize the steps that
lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank or you crossing the Finish Line
are you launching that business are you
having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it that's
where manifesting comes in because we're
not going to focus on the end goal you
gotta pick something that you want in
order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end it's about the
bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists to train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right so manifestation
properly remember what it is manifesting
is preparing your mind body and spirit
to do the work it's aligning your mind
body and spirit with what you want it
removes the obstacles that would
normally stop you which then prepares
and motivates you to take the actions to
succeed so in the case of athletes who
visualize themselves and see themselves
doing all the steps over and over
they're removing the nerves they're
removing all the programming related to
the injury they are prepared their mind
body and spirit to go in and freaking
Dominate and so are you you need someone
who you can trust like if you're giving
someone your money like or you're trying
to take someone's advice or counsel you
need to trust their intentions all right
and so it's not just whether they have
integrity it's whether they have your
best interest in mind all right so I'm
going to get to how I solve for that in
a second but if that is the first
character trait of you need that you
need of a council of somebody of any
kind of council really whether it's
investment law Etc the second is
efficacy or their skill set right so
let's think of both let's think of just
different scenarios here so let's say
you might trust your mom implicitly but
she doesn't have the skill of knowing
much about you know how to structure
insurance policies or trusts or you know
investments in Tech startups right you
might not know how that skill but you
might trust her intention right for you
specifically on the reverse of that you
might see that there's this person who's
got lots of skill is prodigious in this
but it also means that they know exactly
how to screw you if they want to right
which is one of the double-sided things
of being really good at something right
you know all the details you know how to
write the agreement structure the deals
in order to make sure that you you know
get the best outcome right and so the
idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counselor from I have to look at these
two things all right so here's how I
test for the Integrity piece and here's
how you can kind of like you can control
for risk here right one is I always try
and interview as many advisors as
humanly possible all right and I do that
because I'm going to get as much
information from each of the council
during this process that will give me
perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the Integrity
piece is that I try and have a line
incentives now a lot of times there are
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah but
they aren't incentivized to sell it for
as much as possible they're incentivized
to sell it as fast as possible and get a
deal closed all right and so think about
this for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars is a normal you know that like
that's normal that's the market price
right but for you to make an extra let's
say twenty five thousand or fifty
thousand dollars would be really
material that would be a huge extra
outcome for you you would probably push
a lot harder to get the extra 25 or 50
000 now let's say that um you could
probably sell it in a day at 450 000
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of five hundred thousand dollars
right is 25 Grand okay and so for them
the the fifty thousand dollar decrease
to drop you from 500 to 450 means that
they're going to give up twenty five
hundred dollars so they're gonna make
twenty two thousand five hundred so let
me ask you a question now in the reverse
if they sell for 525 they're going to
get 27 500 right and so it's a five
thousand dollar swing off of a you know
25 000 nut for them and one of them
might take them three months and one of
them might take them a day so what is
their incentive
their incentive is to get the is to make
as much money as possible per unit of
time and so they're incentivized to sell
as fast as possible and so this is one
of those things where you have to put
your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when I say there's
two aspects that I look for Council or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally Insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
Integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below four
hundred thousand dollars I'll give you
three percent on anything between 400
and 450 and then from 450 and up I'll
give you 20 right or 15 or whatever
right and so now they're highly
incentivized to push and now your
incentives are aligned because each
increment for you is worth almost as
much it is to them and that is how you
would align incentives all right now how
do you test for the second thing which
is their skill set this one's hard all
right especially if you don't have the
perspective from which to make a
judgment which when I answer new things
when I'm trying to learn about trust and
I'm trying to learn about investment
things and different Vehicles I'm
learning about storage units more about
multi like you're like oh man there's so
much stuff and there's so much Nuance
that you have to have right and so the
first thing is I like to usually read
two to three books on the topic all
right and I read two to three books just
so I don't appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try talk as to as
many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my my investments I
know she has my best at heart but she
has no idea what she's doing and then I
don't want somebody who absolutely knows
what they're doing and does not have my
best interest at heart right which
honestly unfortunately is a lot more of
the cases that that you'll come up with
and candidly you know a lot of times
they're literally incentivized against
you you know uh in the insurance
industry they're they're kind of
incentivized to rip you off it's it's
it's pretty terrible and there's a lot
of Industries like that mortgage brokers
are incentivized to rip you off and so
you really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with I
think one of my first things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence yeah
surprising because no one wants to hire
a monk and so they rejected you but
that's not personal because they didn't
meet me in person but what if they had
me right so that's the first thing the
first step is don't take all fear
failure I'll give an example me and you
we reach out to countless guests to be
on our podcast which they know all the
time I'm saying all the time but if I
don't hear a no from the guest directly
that's not a no like someone's team can
say no someone's assistant can say no
someone's PR team can say no but until
they say no personally it's not a no
okay but when they do say no then that's
enough yeah so then let's move how do
you deal with that type of failure yes
so if I deal with a failure where
someone meets me in person and gets to
know no Jay you're horrible you suck
like I don't want to deal with a monk
ever in my life yeah I would never go on
your show I'm never listening to you
never yeah then how do you deal with
that type of so I've had you say this
I've said a couple of times and I'm sure
it's been repeated a bunch of times
around how I genuinely believe failure
has feedback feedback and and so for me
it's like failure has the ability to
actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games you know on
the big stages you didn't have the
skills you didn't have the teamwork you
guys weren't hungry enough you weren't
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah I think a lot of people can do that
in life but we're so afraid to like go
on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make a
fight they didn't make the finals they
lost and then they realized they need to
get the team and they need to find their
I think they're bringing Dennis Rodman
and then they start bringing in all
these other players that strengthen
whereas if they would have just said oh
we got the best player in the world we
just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am
no matter how successful the person is
that you're looking at and wishing you
could be like them and thinking that
they have everything all figured out the
one thing that I can promise you is that
all of us struggle on the inside that is
just a reality of The Human Condition
once you understand that that is a
reality that that's just a part of the
human condition then you can begin to
ideally let yourself off the hook and
that you're not spending a lot of time
um stuck there but to give you a
specific example from my life the
biggest one the most harrowing one that
I went through was in film school so uh
to cut a very long story short I went to
film School believed that I had innate
talent I went into film school with a
fixed mindset
um I did very well at the beginning of
film school and that all to me felt like
it was proof that I was right that I was
naturally gifted that I was a born
Storyteller and that I was going to go
and have an illustrious career and I
actually went through a fascinating
period in film school where I was both
terrified that secretly I wasn't good
enough and but at the same time actually
believed that I was naturally gifted and
this is what I was meant to do and every
bit of feedback that I got in either
direction was
it made me believe to the core of my
being that it was true so when I would
do something poorly I would think see
that part of me that was convinced that
I actually don't have talent you were
right and then I would do something well
and the part of me that believed that
was like see I knew it you were born for
this and it all came crashing down as I
worked my way up the ranks at USC Film
School
um only four people are chosen to direct
what's known as the senior thesis film
or a 480. and I was one of the four
people picked and I was like see I knew
it man I'm born for this of course I got
picked to do one of the senior thesis
films that just makes sense I'm I'm that
good and I thought okay cool the thing
that makes the thesis film so important
is the film School pays your budget to
make this film so at a time where
there's no YouTube there's no iPhones
like filming is an expensive Endeavor
here you've got somebody that's paying
for it and that becomes your calling
card to the industry so George Lucas
famously made one of these films and
obviously we know how his career ended
up working out and they showed us his
480 by the way and it was amazing it was
amazing and so you could see that here
was this gifted filmmaker and so I have
that in my head like look at George
Lucas's film's absolutely brilliant he's
gone on to have this brilliant career
I'm gonna make an equally brilliant film
or maybe a little more brilliant and
then I'm gonna go become the next Lucas
or the next Spielberg and I'm going to
take that film and get my three picture
deal
and I proceeded to
runs smack Bang into one immutable truth
and that was that I wasn't a talented
filmmaker
and I don't say that to be humble I say
that out of truth because I didn't have
the skill set to make a good film once
the level of complexity had gone beyond
a certain level so I had thrived in
these really short really simple films
and then once you're talking actors and
dialogue and you know the things that
would come close to what we would
recognize as a normal film uh I had no
idea what I was doing and
try and try as I might I couldn't figure
out how to make the film come out well
and it didn't come out well and I was
mortified and I was embarrassed and I
never wanted anybody to see that film
and I was really and truly devastated so
I want you to imagine your whole life so
what I graduated at like 22. so from 12
to 22
all I knew was I wanted to be a
filmmaker and my whole life was moving
towards that and it looked like I had
the natural gift and of course if you're
going to be an artist you're either born
with it or you're not right that's all
anybody said I can't express enough in
the 80s and 90s when I grew up when
people talked about art you either had
it or you didn't and that was that there
was no sense of growth mindset Carol
dweck had not written the book yet and
so it wasn't even like I knew there was
a growth mindset and a fixed mindset I
just knew you're either born with it or
you're not
the great news was I was born with it
here we go it's going to be amazing and
then boom I can't do it and I realize oh
my God I wasn't born with anything I
don't know how to do this there is a
tremendous amount of process to this art
and I don't know that at all but of
course as I'm in the middle of it I just
think my world has come crashing down
I'm not gifted I will never be gifted
and therefore I will never be a
filmmaker I will never make anything of
myself and just it was a downward spiral
of epic proportions
and at the height of that I would go
home from my dead-end job and I would
lay
face down on the carpet because I
couldn't afford furniture and
literally just sit there I can still
feel
that cheap nylon carpet and the way that
it felt on my face as I laid there
thinking well
my life is effectively over certainly
the
my life that was working towards a dream
is over
and
now it's just about finding a way to be
the smartest person in the room and if
that means that I have to go and work a
dead-end job to be the smartest person
in the room then that's what I'll do and
so I used to go and interview for jobs
having nothing to do with film
because I felt totally broken and
my goal was to at some point in the
interview have the interviewer say
you're so smart why are you interviewing
for this role and because I had a fixed
mindset and I so needed that praise from
the outside I was putting myself in
these super weird and useless positions
just to get that little nugget of oh my
God like you're so smart
and I had to put myself in sort of worse
and worse company to get to that point
and
finally and I don't remember what it was
that
led me to this idea of brain plasticity
but somewhere in the depths of my
despair I realized
can we get better maybe we can and so I
started reading about the brain
and that started to plant seeds in my
mind that maybe brain plasticity was
real and maybe I could get better and
just because I wasn't good at film today
maybe I could get better at film down
the road and I ended up getting a job
teaching film because remember those
that can do those that can't teach so I
felt like okay well I can teach this
even if I can't do it and then so
between reading about the brain and
realizing wait a second
if I work at this thing I actually get
better my brain actually changes and I
become better at something and
given you know having gone through
however many years of schooling I'd been
through I started thinking about like
wait a second you would come into any
class and the funny thing is as a kid I
remember every grade just being
absolutely terrified that well I did
okay at being a fourth grader but Mom
I'm going to get devastated as a fifth
grader I don't know what I'm doing and
no matter how many times my mom would
console me and say remember they're
going to teach you how to learn the
things that a fifth grader needs to know
they don't expect you to already know it
it just wouldn't sink in and so I was
sort of back in that moment of you know
I don't know how to do this
but maybe
my mom is right maybe the
neuroscientists are right and maybe I
can learn
to become that thing I want to become I
start teaching film and as I'm teaching
it I realize wait I'm helping my
students become better filmmakers so if
I can help them become better filmmakers
and brain plasticity is really true then
I could get better as a filmmaker myself
and that that realization changed the
rest of my life and this is why I am so
obsessed with the idea of
a growth mindset in brain plasticity
because the biology backs it up and once
you understand it's what I call the only
belief that matters the only belief that
matters is that if you put time and
energy
into getting better at something you'll
actually get better it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that uh he knows the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's starting to exercise
or eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they're comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there are certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds the demand
so how do you increase demand I'm sorry
how do you increase capacity well you
feel the edges and go one more you feel
the tension and keep doing it you feel
the desire to quit but then you do as
much as you can and as you do as much as
you can you get mentally stronger
physically stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results make your
calendar your life this is how you start
to live in intentional life because
you've designed it you've put it in your
calendar not just the business things
when we think about a calendar it's
usually your business stuff okay I got a
meeting here I gotta I gotta send my
newsletter out I have to whatever the
things are for your business life right
you're if you're an entrepreneur you
probably have some of your business
things put in your calendar I'm not
talking just about that I'm talking
about your life
talking about how do you live an
intentional Life by structuring
every day
what ends up happening inside of that is
oh my gosh that's too much structure I
can't stick to it that's too it's too
overwhelming I need free time I need
free time in my calendar great put free
time in your calendar
if you know that you need two hours a
week to have nothing in your calendar
okay
then when is that gonna happen
this is how you reduce stress and
anxieties because you've actually
scheduled in your two hour break and
nothing else comes in because when you
don't schedule your break here's what
happens
other things are going to come up that's
a priority other people's emergencies
other people's phone calls and texts and
emails and social media and then what
does that what happens you lead back
down to stress anxiety overwhelm
you block off your time you build your
your ideal life
I was talking entrepreneur yesterday who
I'm mentoring and he he his business
blowing up this business is blowing up
it's amazing
um on his way to seven Figures it's
crazy
and he's struggling with his health
going to doctor's appointments
struggling has lots of inflammation and
I suppose you okay so you need to you
need to eat better you need to work out
more you need to have a kind of healthy
lifestyle you you already know this I'm
not telling you anything new
but it's on his calendar
so we loaded his calendar and his
calendar is all of his business stops
like okay well where are you where is
the physical activity in your calendar
and where are you prepping for the meals
that you're going to eat because when
you just show up on a good morning hey
have a great day awesome okay now you're
really hungry there's nothing healthy in
the fridge what do you do you go for you
go for junk or you go do takeout
because you didn't plan because it
wasn't in your calendar
you need to schedule it you need to
schedule when you're going to go buy
food if you're going to order out how
many times a week do you want to order
out like schedule this stuff in as Jocko
willing says discipline equals freedom
you want this life it's entirely
possible
but you have to have the discipline in
your calendar to actually follow through
on it
when you find yourself not following the
calendar
it's because of a couple reasons the
first is because
you set goals that are not actually
possible there wasn't enough flexibility
in your calendar right that you say how
many times you've set a goal and you
said I'm going to work out every day for
for two hours and then and then what
happens you don't because it's
unrealistic because that's not gonna
happen
and what you're also doing is training
yourself that you suck that when you set
goals that you don't follow through
that's a problem
then the next time you set a goal you're
gonna
tell yourself oh I'm not going to do
this one either because I always set
goals and don't follow through you don't
you stop believing in yourself it's not
even other people believing in you you
don't believe in yourself because you've
taught yourself that when you do some
when you say you're going to do
something you don't actually do it
that's a problem
so how do we start to fix that we start
to fix that by actually creating a
calendar that reflects her entire life
so think about your goals let's let's
break this down right step one think
about the life that you want what's the
life that you want
how much time do you want to spend
sleeping how much time do you want to
spend with family how much time do you
want to spend this will change right if
you're a husband wife single kids
anybody sick in their family those they
will shift our calendar accordingly but
right now think about your life right
now how much time do you want to spend
with your family how much time you want
to spend in your business how much you
want to how much time you want to spend
do you need for yourself
free time or meditation time or working
out time or going out in nature time how
much time you want to spend planning
that as opposed to randomly hoping that
your day happens as you want it it's not
having no plan and no schedule is the
path to stress and overwhelm
having a decent plan even a poor plan at
the beginning starts to create the
momentum that you need so think about
how much time you want to spend in those
categories because you don't want to
spend all day sleeping you don't you
don't want to spend all day with your
family you don't want to spend all day
with your kids with your husband wife
you don't want to spend all day working
you don't want to spend all day relaxing
either like the idea of work sitting on
the beach might be great right now
because you feel stressed overwhelmed
and may hate your life but you don't
want to spend all day every day at a
beach you would get so bored the trick
is not to escape your current life
because then you're going back to it
right so Escape for two weeks the life
that you hate to then come back to it
the trick is to build a better life and
it starts with an intentional calendar
so think about how much time you want to
spend on the different categories
then step two I would split it up
between things that you need to do daily
and things you need to do either on a
weekly or monthly basis so daily is
daily routine so I have a morning
routine I'll wake up I'll put on music
I'll set the intention for the day I'll
go for a walk outside it's the snowing
in Toronto this morning I still go for
my walk outside I'll do some kind of
workout whether it's swimming or yoga
some kind of workout and then I'll start
my day
right what I do is start my day like my
business day those are different days of
the week okay so just do morning routine
and then evening routine so we bucket
these but these are mostly the same
every day evening routine
uh I'll eat dinner with Nina at six I
have blocked off an hour to be able to
spend time with her at seven I'll stream
on my gaming YouTube channel answering
questions from you at eight I'll spend
time with my son Hayden usually playing
Minecraft or catching up or doing
something together nine will sit down
and watch a show with Nina right now
we're watching Wheel of Time on Amazon
10 I'll take the dogs out I'll come back
up I'll clean the dishes and whatever
else needs to be cleaned in the condo 11
o'clock I'm getting ready for bed
reading the book and hopefully passing
out right evening routine pretty
structured pretty similar every day
what it does is make sure I have time
for all the stuff I want to have time
with my son I want to have time with my
wife I want to have time to eat dinner
and not be stressed out and rush into
the next thing I want to make sure that
there's still time to do family admin
stuff like take the dogs out and clean
the place because
sure if I miss it one day everything
would be fine but if every day I'm not
taking the dogs out and not clean up the
place that's going to cause strain on my
relationship with Nina and also not
being happy with myself right so all
these things are designed now that
structure may sound overwhelming and
crazy for you awesome you have different
goals maybe you need four hours of open
time every night or four hours of
meditation time every night don't don't
take my calendar I'm just giving you an
example you need to create your calendar
for yourself
so what's your daily morning routine and
daily evening routine put it down create
it
then inside of the week you might have
different different things on different
days I structured my entire day so
Monday's mentoring day I just mentored
my team Tuesday is YouTube day where i'm
filming content today's a Tuesday I
don't know when the video comes out for
you but for me I'm filming on a Tuesday
Wednesday is my project day it's totally
open to work on projects that I want to
work on Thursdays public facing dates
interviews podcasts shows Etc so Tuesday
Thursdays are busy this I'm not being
creative I'm just work work work work
work work work work very little free
time
and I'm doing tons of videos and tons of
interviews Wednesday in the middle is
totally open
like okay all the ideas that I've had
all the projects that I've wanted to do
here's my time in my calendar to do it
because if I didn't have that spot then
I would feel again stressed out
overwhelmed I feel like I'm just
answering all these
messages and just creating content and
just going on people's shows and I have
no time to create my own stuff perfect
Wednesdays Done Right Wednesdays I would
use to write my book
it's the whole day totally open Friday's
my CEO day
where I work on the business instead of
in the business Saturday is fun day
so Saturday if I'm doing anything that's
work related has to be cleared through
Nina first and better be something big
so I lose out on some opportunities
because Saturday is is fun day and then
Sunday is family at midday cleaning up
the condo grocery shopping
Costco whatever whatever needs to get
done that's my life
right that fits for me let me leave the
total worst thing for you it probably is
awesome figure out your life
morning routine evening routine your
entire life not just what you need to do
as an entrepreneur for your business but
for your life as a husband or a wife or
a son or a daughter or a parent your
life time you need for yourself
create it
morning routine evening routine and then
the rest of the week what are you gonna
do
it matters this is how you start to
build consistent habits
the next step is to
evaluate at the end of the week how well
you did the whole point isn't to beat
yourself up of how you sucked and how
you missed this and schedules don't work
for you Etc but to evaluate it's not
that you can't stick to a schedule it's
that the schedule wasn't a good enough
schedule for you
so what needs to change in the schedule
for example for dinner for me
these are these micro tweaks you might
have to make a big tweak but a micro
trick for me was I had my dinner from 5
30 to 6 with Nina
and it just felt too rushed I said okay
well we don't usually take an hour to
eat we eat small meals so we usually eat
it pretty quickly
um so okay half an hour perfect easy
enough time
but it kind of felt rushed getting into
it so even though it doesn't take us a
full hour to eat I book off an hour to
eat that's an example of a micro
adjustment so think about where do you
feel stressed out in your calendar
you've done it for a week right you plan
out your calendar for the next week
perfect morning routine eating routine
what happens during the week during the
day perfect you evaluate at the end of
the week where did you feel stressed
where did it not work out
where did you miss something
and if it's a one-off thing okay fine
something happened but if it's happening
consistently
then your calendar is broken
then you need to spend more time here if
you get to the end of the week and you
feel stressed out overwhelmed what are
you feeling I feel like oh I don't have
enough time to myself this is what the
the person I was mentoring yesterday
said like I look at your calendar this
week I couldn't do that I have no time
to myself
great schedule and time to yourself
because if you don't schedule in time
for yourself chances are something's
going to jump on top of it and you'll
never have time for yourself I'm giving
you the answer
so where is time for yourself
oh Saturday morning perfect how much
time you need four hours great
put that in give yourself five hours as
a buffer just in case now you got the
time
and protect that time
so it's making those micro adjustments
as you go until your first week if
you've never done this or feels
overwhelming or stressed for you the
first week is probably going to be a
disaster that's okay
you did some of the things that's better
than not doing any of the things so
let's make some progress now at the end
of the week look back and iterate
change it make some micro tweaks okay
that clearly didn't work here okay so
next week I'm going to try doing this
and what you do is get closer and closer
and closer to creating a schedule that
actually fits for who you are for your
goals and it's not going to be my
schedule it's not going to be Steve
Jobs's schedule or Jordan Peterson's
schedule anybody else it's gonna be one
that you designed tailored for you and
then the third last step to it is you're
going to grow and change as a person and
your schedule needs to change and adjust
alongside so there's a very big
difference between having a job and
being an entrepreneur there's also a
difference between being a solo
entrepreneur and then having a team does
it even having five people on your team
or one person to five people to
37 people now for me there's a big
difference in how I need to manage my
time I didn't I have a whole day
dedicated to mentoring I didn't need
that when it's just me
right things have to change if you're
single versus in a relationship or
single versus engaged versus married and
how long you've been married
or if you have kids or not or planning
to have kids right like your your
choices will change as you change as a
human so even if you create the perfect
schedule right now for yourself and
that's reflective of today like it's a
perfect schedule for this week right now
chances are in a couple months you're
gonna have to make some micro tweaks
because something's changed in your life
and that's okay that doesn't mean that
your schedule sucks just means it needs
an evolution as you evolve your schedule
has to evolve with you
you are what you consistently do and the
way to become that person that you want
to build the life that you want it's not
just having some
vision board for yourself
it's by actually putting into your
calendar let your calendar be your
bucket list
that if you start actually living this
life and doing these things it leads to
a happy whole life for you
treat your personal just as important as
your business
everything gets put into the calendar
and then adjust
and now you're building a life that you
want
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the simple routines that
generate massive wealth check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there you know like when you're
driving and the cop lights go on and
that your car goes but then when the cop
Drives By you're like you feel real good
and then you start driving with two
hands and the speed limit for about four
minutes and then you go back to being
like ridiculous